la periodista rusa marina oxxean y cova
tendrá que pagar 50 mil rublos
aproximadamente
780 dólares por desacreditar al ejército
de su país según dictaminó un tribunal
de moscú la comunicadora utilizó las
redes sociales para manifestarse en
contra de la guerra y el presidente
vladimir putin
estaba claro desde el principio que esta
audiencia en la corte fue organizada
para intimidarme para intimidar a
cualquiera que no esté de acuerdo con el
gobierno y quien está en contra de la
guerra obvian y cova acaparó la atención
mundial en marzo de este año cuando
protagonizó una protesta en contra de lo
que el kremlin llama su operación
especial en ucrania no a la guerra no
crean en la propaganda les mienten dijo
la periodista en medio de una
transmisión en vivo del noticiero del
canal estatal channel one luego del
suceso obvian y cova fue despedida y se
refugió unos meses en alemania sin
embargo en julio decidió volver a rusia
donde fue arrestada brevemente tras ser
acusada de violar las leyes de protesta
este registro este es el primer caso en
la historia de la ley rusa en el que las
autoridades prohíben directamente hablar
sobre ciertos temas y de determinada
manera
la comunicadora apelar a la decisión y
asegura que seguirá oponiéndose a la
guerra en ucrania